je sais moi des fois j'achète trop
encore dit j'essaie de planifier de
mieux en mieux pour le gaspillage là
j'ai toujours ma montagne de crudités en
partant
marcelle bastien a toujours eu le souci
de manger sainement c'est encore plus
important depuis qu'il est à la retraite
elle vit seule dans une résidence pour
aînés on a tout le temps voulu de lire
les étiquettes faire attention bon est
ce qu'on mange été dérobés lors ok mais
de gérer aussi des fois le manque
d'appétit
c'est la base
mais l'international
et
soucieuse de préserver son autonomie
elle a participé avec enthousiasme au
projet qui réunit des étudiantes en
nutrition de l'université de montréal et
des résidentes de sa rpa
les étudiantes ont répondu aux
préoccupations des aînés en s'appuyant
sur des données scientifiques
moi ce que j'ai appris c'est que la
personne âgée a besoin de plus de
protéines ce que je ne savais pas toutes
les sources de protéines que qu'elles
ont mentionné comment les intégrer
facilement dans notre alimentation tous
les jours allez faire encore plus
griller pour sa part subi ce crunch
gauche mais surtout c'est vraiment
intéressant je partage a permis de faire
découvrir des astuces pour être duire
plus de protéines végétales dans les
collations
soit mais oui
je suis de plus en plus végétarien ma
gueule parfaire encore parce qu'il ne
s'use pas toujours possible c'est
meilleur marché que de la viande parce
quils à la viande maintenant
ça va nous aider
une chimie s'est installée entre les
deux générations post a peut-être pas de
notre façon cuisinella mais je trouve
que ça c'est trop pour moi je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant d'avoir ce contact
avec les jeunes qui nous apportent des
choses nouvelles dans ma formation j
avais pas vraiment vu et cette clientèle
lui non plus ne m'envoyez et les
personnels mais plus c'est vraiment ch
et celle des dons qu'il ya un peu plus
avancer dans la vie puis ici mais on les
voit vraiment dans une autre milieu
c'est pas des personnes qui ont
l'habitude d'intégrer dans nos
programmes de formation alors que c'est
le québec d'aujourd'hui et sa voix est
aussi le québec de demain d'ici dix ans
on prévoit qu'à peu près une personne
sur ko plus de 65 ans le projet s'étale
sur trois ans grâce à un don du groupe
sélection retraite qui permet aux
étudiantes d'installer un bureau dans la
résidence pendant les stages et les
projets spéciaux ça fait que la cuisine
ici est amélioré aussi parce que la
direction est sensible à cette europe
puis de l'alimentation pour ce soit
aussi agréable quand on a décidé de
parler de protéines c'était certain pour
nous qu'on a qu'on aborderait les
protéines végétales et notre agenda
caché et ai dit aussi bien les protéines
végétales on n'a pas le choix on va se
diriger vers elle pour des questions de
développement durable
mais on voit se diriger vers elle
également contenu de notre portefeuille
d'autres thèmes seront abordés et les
vidéos destinés aux aînés autonomes
seront partagées dans l'ensemble des
résidences du groupe sélection retraite
éventuellement le grand public il y aura
aussi accès ici à nourrice despatie
radio-canada mourir